look if you want an unbiased review you
better head elsewhere cuz me I've got
this axe to grind yeah it's true
I've seen the Lion King I feel like in
some ways this is penance for the fact
that I've gotten away with not having to
see any of the Disney remakes up to this
point if you haven't seen my previous
videos on this well link up there feel
free to check them out but put it super
quickly I have a massive fundamental
philosophical issue with very existence
of these things in the first place I
don't believe that they should exist and
that's not me me going there y'all stink
because I haven't seen them I refuse to
see them I will not throw money at these
projects I find them just infuriating on
so many levels
unfortunately my kid really wanted to
see this one and she loves animals
pretty much more than anything else she
likes animals more than people so I I
did not have it in my heart to say no to
her to this cuz I knew she really wanted
to see it and I've now seen it and like
I said in a way I feel like it's penance
because I managed to dodge all the other
ones and instead have to go with what is
literally the most pointless one of all
of these so the Lion King yeah I came in
here with a massive chip on my shoulder
and a huge huge bias duh do I think I
could have even possibly been slightly
open-minded about this honestly no the
only way this movie was ever gonna be
any good for me this is not me saying
what anyone should think but it only
reason the only way I was not gonna hate
this movie is if it completely failed to
be what the marketing was selling
because what the marketing was selling
was it's the Lion King in photorealistic
animation but it's the same story with
the same characters of the same song and
the same plot and it is
and again on principle I hate that and
don't want it so unless it was something
completely different from that I was
never going to like this so it's not a
question of how well it's do it does
what it set out sets out to do I believe
fundamentally about what it sets out to
do is a thing not worth doing I believe
this is this entire thing these movies
in general this one in particular is
pointless on the scale that we have not
seen since since the remake of psycho in
the 90s anyway let's get into some
specific points on this because I'm not
gonna reach read all my philosophical
issues again there's other videos for
you to see that let's break down this
one in particular and yeah this is just
gonna be me complaining pretty much the
whole time so if you can't handle it or
you don't want to see it that's what
it's gonna be so there is one thing
about this movie that is better than the
original and that is Donald Glover is a
better grown Simba than Matthew
Broderick was now that I not to diminish
what Donald Glover does with a part cuz
he actually does it well but part of
that has to do with the fact that
Matthew Broderick as symbol was one of
the inherent weak links of the original
Lion King he was okay initially but when
he had to face down against scar like he
sounded weak he did not sound like
anything scar should be afraid of he
just didn't have any authority or
strength in his voice Donald Glover was
able to pull that off so he is a better
adult Simba then was in the original 2d
hand-drawn animated version that's the
only thing that's better the only thing
that jumped out to me as being as good
while still being different from the
original was a Pumbaa Seth Rogen's a
good Pumbaa
when he's speaking he can't sing like
Seth Rogen like legitimately can't sing
like to the point that I'm like why
didn't you auto-tune him so he's on key
I guess they thought it was endearing
that Pumbaa was off key I don't know why
but so that's about all the praise I'm
gonna have for this because it's not
just that the animation is
photorealistic they also made the
decision to shoot this as much as a
looking like they had animals who could
act and film them making it look as
natural and realistic as possible which
is stupid it's very impressive on a
technical level it's in very impressive
feet and if anything is ever gonna come
out of this I really hope that they take
the technology that they have fine-tuned
between the jungle book and now this and
do something original with it so that
all the effort that was poured into this
technology gets put to some good some
use something not pointless but the
problem with it being all realistic and
everything is that it loses the unique
visual aesthetic because you need to
remember the original 2d animator STUV
all those characters way more expressive
than anything that is in this
live-action because they are cartoons
they're allowed to have more cartoonish
expressions when you restrict them to
the actual facial movements of a lion
well a lion doesn't have a lot of facial
expressions and it puts a heck of a lot
more weight on the voice actors who
again are fine but when you're taking
tools out of the tool box by making it
this realistic thing because you
actually severely restrict the ability
of these things to emot-- worth a dang
and it's also with the lighting like
they think back to the movie I don't
know when the last time was anybody and
you folks have seen the original version
but go back and look there are some bold
color choices at various points I just
can't wait to be king go goes bright
with purples and pinks and oranges and
be prepared it starts out with a sickly
green and it builds into this red and
there's some really interesting colors
that run through it and help set the
mood the tone and keep the thing lively
and bright and animated whereas this
like it's all muted earth tones because
that's what's natural and I don't care
if it's natural realistic it's far less
interesting to look at
I feel like this movie right now I feels
like Disney with these things is going
through the same problem that has
plagued the video games of the last few
generations which is all this emphasis
on Oh make it realistic make it more
realistic and they forget the question
of like okay so it's more realistic is
it actually more fun is it actually more
fun to be stuck behind a bit of wall and
only get to carry two weapons at a time
while facing nothing but humans who are
on the other side of a conflict versus a
bright colorful world where I can jump
15 feet with a single button and can
carry every single weapon in the game on
me at all times what's more fun and in
very much the same way Disney doesn't
seem to realize how going for realistic
really hampers the narrative and the way
that it's told and honestly it makes the
song stick out like a sore thumb because
they can't go bright and colorful with
when the songs kick in the way that they
did with the animated it's still the
same muted palette and so now the songs
feel really out of place and actually
I'm okay I don't know how they possibly
miss history there was one thing that I
had assumed they were gonna do cuz this
movie's longer this movie is a half hour
longer rituals 90 minutes this is two
hours and so I had assumed part of the
reason for that is they added more songs
that they took the songs from the stage
version of The Lion King that were
created for that with LeBeau M who
helped create a lot of the music for the
original and we're going to inject them
into this a couple of and not all of
them not all of them that are unique to
the stage version are great the madness
of King scar that's not worth porting
over but he lives in you
totally worth porting over and
Shadowlands how do how do you get beyond
say as Nala and not give her Shadowlands
to sing it's such an awesome song and
instead they come up with this original
song that gets sung as Nala and Simba
I'm gonna be talking spoilers you all
know
this thing when Nala and Simba are
coming back to the pride lands there's
this very out of place like I've already
said the musical numbers are out of
place but even out of place because it
doesn't match the tone in the sound of
the other songs that they give to
Beyonce I guess one to give her a solo
song and two to have a quote-unquote
original song in this movie so that they
can submit it for the Oscar at the end
of the year so like why would you do
that why why did you think that was a
good use of Beyonce when you had shadow
lands right there and if you've never
heard these songs if you never heard he
lives in you or shadow lands just look
him up just iu2 I don't find them find
them listen to them Spotify don't care
they're awesome songs especially if you
like the Lion King soundtrack and you'll
hear those who go why didn't they use
those exactly so okay I mentioned the
fact that this is about a half hour
longer this is the big thing that I want
to drill in out on this the original
film and actually I would say a good
chunk of the Disney Renaissance I would
say in particular Little Mermaid Beauty
and the Beast and Lion King also Aladdin
but though maybe a little bit less with
that one those are monuments to
efficient storytelling they run between
85 and 95 minutes and they do that
telling these complete stories with
everything that needs to be there
because not an inch is wasted they don't
spend time over explaining they don't
spend time lingering things that don't
need to be lingered on and it doesn't
mean that those films move at a
breakneck speed they move at a
reasonable pace but they know how to
compress things they know how to
accomplish multiple things in one scene
they know when a scenes made its point
and when to move on this film is this
should be taught in film classes to back
to back the original Lion King and then
this to show how inefficient the
storytelling of this is any scene any
line of dialogue that gets lit while I
say any scene every scene gets lifted
but any time they lift a specific piece
of dialogue in the original if it was
once
and the new one it's three sentences
I've got specific examples I have notes
okay so here's a couple of examples
so after Mufasa has died and scar comes
and he's laying the guilt onto Simba and
he says to cept what he says - Simba in
the original anime version he you know
the king is dead if it wasn't for you
he'd still be alive huh
what would your mother think and in the
new version
he doesn't lead up what would your
mother think a son who cuz a father a
prince who killed a king like why did
you add those two extra sentences they
don't add anything don't make the point
stronger they make the same point again
and just eat up time hold on I've got
more that is not isolated okay
the mouse you remember it skaars
introduction there's a little mouse and
in the original animated film it comes
out of a little hole and in a rock wall
comes out boom scars pause on it we
start how does it go in this one we see
the mouse skip through a puddle climb up
a rock up some more rocks into the cave
I'll do a bit of grass then scar finally
shows up why I don't know so okay so the
lion sleeps tonight when to moon and
Puma are seeing that that is a gag from
the original and in the original they
get as far as the as the chorus once and
then it moves on this one they get
through two verses and a bunch of other
animals join in why because apparently
eating up more time makes it somehow
more relevant oh here's the best one so
remember Rafiki realizing the symbol was
still alive the way that plays out in
the original if Simba just kind of
collapses on these on just this edge and
the pollen in like grass and stuff goes
up there is one shot of this stuff kind
of blowing across the you know the bit
of arid desert between the pride lands
and where Timon and Pumbaa are and then
Rafi he snatches it out of the air looks
into it with his mystical whatever and
realizes simple still alive that's it
basically three shots Simba collapsing
stuff going Rafiki has it in this one
mm-hmm
huh Simba collapses a little bit of his
fur it's for instead of a thing so we
have to watch the fur drift through the
air we have to see it fall into water we
have to see it picked up by a bird put
into a nest have it discarded from the
nest by another bird have that discarded
fur land on the leaves of a tree get
eaten by a giraffe
we then see it in a roll of dung being
rolled by a dung beetle yes slightly
decent laugh there because it was kind
of unexpected but there's no reason for
this to be drying out so long the dung
breaks up I think it got caught on the
wind again I can't even remember then
know it can picked up by an ant in an
ant marches along with it and then it's
finally picked up by Rafiki it takes
about five times as long why why this is
incredibly inefficient storytelling
you're taking three times as long to
make the same point oh and one other
because it happened at the very end and
it really ticked me off so you know
basically the hyenas are backing scar
and Simba's there and they go after each
other now in the original film as soon
as a fight starts the lionesses boom
they just get into the fight no first we
have to stop in here not like a lions
attack what was the point of that okay I
got more gripes to list on this Timon
and Pumbaa are all kinds of meta which
isn't necessarily complained it's just
weird
like they make a bunch of jokes that
only work if you've seen the original
it's just more begs the question who is
this movie for because there are whole
sections and segments and jokes that
only make sense if you've seen the
original but it is such a direct
retelling anyone who's seen the original
is gonna immediately know none of this
is new anything that's good in this is
only good in it because it was good last
time
this film adds nothing there is one good
gag that they get to do though because
in the original Tim moon gets in the
hula skirt and does his little war are
you kiddin for some bacon and in this he
starts to sing be our guest from buting
the beast that was actually a decent
joke I'll give them that
oh goodness what else do we have here oh
my daughter even mentioned
one you can't tell a lot of these
characters apart again suffering from
the realism
you can't tell most of the hyenas apart
like one of them's got a bit off ear you
can't tell most of the rest of them
apart
you cannot tell Nala from Sarabi until
one of them starts speaking and also
when they're Cubs you can't tell Nala
from Simba until they start speaking and
you go back and watch the cartoon it is
very clear visually the difference
between them to go with Nala and Surabhi
Surabhi is a slightly different shade
her fur and has different eyes and
because they're cartoon eyes they're
huge and the fact that the eyes are
different colors is immediately evident
maybe they had different eyes in this
one I don't know they were little
friggin lyin eyes realistically shaded I
couldn't tell what color their eyes were
so even if that wasn't to be
distinguishing I couldn't see it oh god
um oh because they went with the
naturalistic lighting can you feel the
love tonight happens in the middle of
the day and yes I actually went back and
watched the original it happens as Sun
is setting so it is still kind of
daylight through most of it but by the
time that song ends it is sunset Sun is
down when it at by the time that song
ends in this one the Sun is still
beating for like it's headed down but
it's not even like the red light of
sunset no that's still proper sunlight
can you feel the love tonight doesn't
even go into the night happens in the
middle of the day because they went with
naturalistic lighting which means you
wouldn't have been able to see anything
at night and apparently that's more
important than having the song make any
freaking sense oh and they did a weird
thing with scar where they like he's
made a more he's more threatening and as
far as differences in performance that's
a valid way to do it differently so that
chiwetel ejiofor gets to deliver a
different performance than what Jeremy
Irons did which was very much in the
sort of well gay coded villain I'll talk
about those at some point down the line
but it's a very different feel and
that's fine
here's the problem though because as
much as I might complain about gay coded
villains in the case of something like
The Lion King it does actually serve a
little
of a purpose which is that because scars
you know sarcasm in his backbiting is so
just snark and it comes across more as
him just being sassy
you know nastily so it becomes more
believable that Mufasa hasn't dealt with
him before this here
he seems deathly serious he and it
really feels like GU Foster should be
taking him way more seriously and
actually they even added a bit of
dialogue that scar has challenged Mufasa
previously and lost now Mufasa looks
really stupid for keeping him around
you could argue he was stupid for not
doing something about scar ahead of time
in the original but compare it to this
night and day you could make an argument
before like here
no he's openly severely hostile and not
in a way that could be written off as
just uh that family member no no this
guy feels threatening and he feels
dangerous only hopefully the hyenas
aren't fun anymore
like some of them have jokes but sir I'm
not sorry I'm Shenzi was a voice by
Whoopi Goldberg in the original she's
they turned her into a mini-boss I guess
so Nala can have somebody to face down
at the end but she's all serious and
something but the thing is Whoopi
Goldberg was fun as a hyena but she was
still scared when she needed to be
there's a moment when they first show up
and in Seminole are running away Simba
scratches her face that's a scary moment
from that character you could have her
be intimidating but still have her be
fun what having a fun can't we have fun
anymore
and one more thing and again just sort
of emphasizing who is this movie for
because it seems certain elements of it
seem to only work you've you seen the
original you've seen the original then
you've seen this done better and more
efficiently and more colorfully and that
is Rafiki stick so Rafiki he you know
he's the monkey i don't know exactly
what kind of monkey is but you know with
Simba and everything so in the original
he's always got his stick first time he
shows up he's got the walkie stick he
dangles like the melons over the kid you
know and and
actually the stick even serves a purpose
it's a terrific metaphor that he uses to
literally beat some sense in December
great stuff
they cut that kept all this other crap
and cut that but here was the really
bizarre thing
Ruffini doesn't have a stick until right
before the final scene he pulls it out
of his tree that he lives in he goes my
old friend what old friend we've never
seen this stick before
understand what he means by that the
only reason to stay won't have any
meaning is if you've seen the previous
one and you know he's gonna beat hyenas
around the head with it but we've never
seen him with this friggin stick I did
not enjoy this movie particularly much
if you couldn't guessed this is the
epitome of pointless and I'm not
thrilled that I saw it I think I'm done
I mean I'll just point out it's a half
hour longer but like there's maybe three
minutes of actual substantive new
material basically they had a thing
about Skaar wishing that Surabhi was
this Queen that's like three minutes and
the rest of it the other twenty seven
minutes of at a time
it's the inefficient storytelling that I
was talking about so the Lion King have
you seen it I'm sorry what did you think
about it how mad are you and me that I
just spent this time ripping into it top
to bottom whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
you can do down there the like button is
a big help these days but you can also
subscribe share this video share my
Bible with the world you can also
support this channel at P at the patreon
link down below helps me cover my bills
plus there's other stuff down there
below click on it it'll take you places
but you also don't have to I'd
appreciate it but at the end of the day
folks you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and
griping about CGI lions and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]